[Music]
you said you fancy Jennifer Lawrence
sure she's a really beautiful
oscar-winning actress
I wouldn't go I refuse to have sex with
this glorious creation anyone would even
if it wasn't like say you were a woman
and you weren't even a lesbian and they
went g1f sex of Jennifer Lawrence ago I
might as well right she's so beautiful
so elegant and mysterious eventually is
probably a pain in the ass but why
wouldn't you
I just found the Vinci oh she's
fantastic we've had on the show anyone
could pull it off for 10 minutes I'm I'm
nice for 10 minutes like this all the
time you don't have be around when the
laughter stops starts to cry yes Lauren
I know what you're talking about I'm
always this guy seen that documentary
backing everyone say Jesus
it's kind of a you fell in love with
with your bedtime stories co-star oh
yeah did this and Teresa Palmer Teresa
Palmer I think we have a photo here of
her there she Jesus Christ that's the
photo did I keep her and a candid shot
that was just leaving the office anyway
you fell in love with this woman and you
didn't want to be in love with her so
you used a hypnotist is this right Wow
yes Cohn and everything you said is true
but now I'm going to provide some
mitigation what happened was else making
a film called bedtime stories yes yes
and Teresa Palmer that beautiful woman
we just saw turning herself into a sex
see yeah like a letter C but made a sex
like Sesame Street for perverts which in
light of recent evidence is simply
Sesame Street it's film bedtime stories
and she was so beautiful so radiant and
when I looked at the beauty I thought if
I have that beauty in my life everything
else will not matter that's what I felt
to myself and that's why I think every
time I see Beauty spellbound by its
perfection like somehow it's a conduit
to a holy power so for this is going to
prevent me from being able to have sex
of all of the extras so I needed to get
a hypnotist to unravel the riddle of
love so my consciousness so you hired a
hypnotist to make you not be in love
with Teresa Palmer didn't hire him
is my mate Paul McKenna I know him
anyway he's one of those
neuro-linguistic programming people that
can help you to not say you're scared of
a dog oh I'm scared of a dog he also
don't be scared of a dog but he was
saying suck your weight here we go I'm
not scared of a dog
Cygnet isn't so like bad you didn't pay
him if that's what he does there's more
complex than that Conan but you have
disrupted the anecdote
you're crazy
now listen now listen old chum so you
you go ahead he you get high what do you
do look I'm on this movie if I fall in
love with this woman it's gonna distract
me there's all these beautiful women
everywhere Adam Sandler finds it amusing
when I'm chatting out the different
girls he lives vicariously through me
I cannot lose that relationship help me
he goes alright he go okay right in
first of all I said all that down an
answerphone cuz he didn't answer
I leave long elaborate answer phone
messages as you might imagine then I got
callback from Paul McKenna who's a
British hypnotist respectable
bespectacled man he's kind of like this
and he said he called back and he said
what's the matter Russell some
twisting your melon right that's what's
happening I need your help hypnotize me
any guys okay so you need to imagine her
in acts of sexual congress with
increasingly unattractive men how does
that make you feel go really hurts I
think I love her anyway okay let's try a
new technique think of an L look up to
the lift have your wrist look up to the
rights have your wrist all these
neuro-linguistic programming techniques
right
and I tried the more you okay think
about it having sex with somebody else
now how'd you feel good I still think I
love her he goes okay imagine her head
or a fat woman's body quite like big
woman's that didn't help either
so did any of this work well no actually
what they did instead is that I had sex
with her and a relationship with her and
eventually that does get it out your
system that is the nature of the
chemical imperative to procreate I'm
sorry I didn't design the Mallaby dough
it was some monkeys in the old days
possibly a powerful omnipotent force we
don't know